we've done several videos already where
we're approximating the area under a
curve by breaking up that area into
rectangles and then finding the sum of
those the sum of the areas of those
rectangles as an approximation this was
just this is actually the first example
that we looked at where each of the
rectangles had an equal width so we
equally partitioned the interval between
our two boundaries between a and b
and the height of the rectangle was the
function evaluated at the left endpoint
of each rectangle and we wanted to
generalize it and write it in sigma
notation it looked something like this
and this was one case later on we looked
at a situation where you define the
height by the function value at the
right endpoint or at the midpoint and
then we even constructed trapezoids and
these are all particular instances of
riemann sums
riemann sums so this right over here is
a
riemann
riemann sum and when people talk about
riemann sums they're talking about the
more general notion you don't have to
just do it this way you could use
trapezoids you don't even have to have
equally spaced partitions i used equally
spaced partitions because it made things
a little bit conceptually simpler and
this right here is a picture of the
person that riemann sums was named after
this is bernard riemann and he did many
he made many contributions to
mathematics but what he's most known for
at least if you're taking a first year
calculus course is the riemann sum and
how this is used to define the riemann
integral both newton and leibniz had
come up with the idea of the integral
when they had formulated calculus but
the riemann integral is kind of the most
mainstream formal or i would say
rigorous definition of what an integral
is
so as you can imagine this is one
instance of a riemann sum we have n
right over here if the more the larger n
is the better an approximation it's
going to be so his definition of an
integral which is the actual area under
the curve or his definition of a
definite integral which is the actual
area of under a curve between a and b
is to take this riemann sum to take this
riemann sum it doesn't have to be this
one and take any riemann sum and take
the limit
the limit as n approaches infinity so
just to be clear what's happening when n
approaches infinity let me draw another
diagram here
so
let's say that's my y-axis
this is my x-axis
this is my function
as n approaches infinity so this is a
this is b you're just going to have a
ton of rectangles you're just going to
get a ton
of rectangles over there and they're
going to become better and better
approximations for the actual area and
the actual area under the curve is
donated is denoted by the integral
the integral from a
to b
of f of x times dx and just to make it
you see where this is coming from or how
these notations are closer at least in
my brain how they're connected delta x
was the dit was the distance for each of
these was the width for each of these
sections this right here is delta x so
that
is a delta x this is another delta x
this is another delta x though a
reasonable way to conceptualize what dx
is or what a differential is is this
what delta x approaches if it becomes
infinitely small so you can view this
you can conceptualize this it's not a
very rigorous way of thinking about it
is an infinitely small
infinite
infinitely but not zero
infinitely small infinitely
small
delta x is one way is one way that you
can conceptualize this so once again as
you have your function times a little
small change in delta x and you are
summing although you're summing an
infinite number of these things from a
to b
so i'm going to leave you there just so
you see the connection you know the name
for these things and once again this one
over here this isn't this isn't the only
riemann sum in fact this is often called
the left riemann sum if you're using it
with rectangles you could do a right
riemann sum you could do use the
midpoint you could use a trapezoid but
if you take the limit of any of those
riemann sums as n approaches infinity
then that you get as a as a riemann
definition of the integral now so far we
haven't we haven't talked about how to
actually evaluate this thing this is
just a definition right now
and for that we will do in future videos